is Justin Hartley's wife Rachelle staus
throwing shade a little over a week
after news broke that Justin have filed
for divorce
Chris Shelly is speaking out taking to
Instagram Monday morning with this quote
it's hard to watch people change right
in front of you but it's even harder
remembering who they used to be she
cited author Annie Sean Penn waar for
the powerful words but it's hard not to
question whether they're aimed at
Hartley what's more the 38 year old
actress also tweaked the bio on her
social media app writing the wound is
the place where the light enters you
roomie hashtag selling sunset hashtag
days we met through sort of like a
series of friends me inquiring about her
at a certain point and then her kind of
inquiring about me at a certain point
and then us putting the pieces together
and realizing that we were inquiring
about each other so this is a star filed
for divorce and his wife of two years in
late November but according to the court
documents obtained by ET Hartley listed
their date of separation as July 8th
2019 interestingly they've been spotted
together several times since here they
are looking happy and in love at a
Golden Globes party just days before the
filing et even spoke with them at the
Emmys in September what I mean come on
give me a break right what a vision it's
incredible it's incredible
the two dated for three years before
getting married in October 2017 it's
kind of cool like to be able to call her
wife that's kind of neat you know and to
be referred to as husband that's kind of
cool
and often gushed about each other to ET
over the years all right guys best thing
about being married so far oh gosh I
like just saying wife
yeah great right
they have no kids together and it's
unclear if they have a prenup
[Music]